[Music]
hardly any other video game adaption is
as popular as sonic the hedgehog
in 2020 the film was not only one of the
last to run regularly in theaters but
also the most successful superhero movie
of the year
after marvel managed to claim the title
for 10 years straight
in today's episode we take a look at
sonic the hedgehog 2 and
everything we already know about the
sequel coming in 2022
so have fun with our newest original
video let's start with a short recap of
the plot from the first part
our favorite hedgehog is on the run from
evil forces that want to use the super
powers to their benefit
his adventure eventually leads him to
the town of green hills in montana
however he's so lonely there that he
runs around a baseball field out of
frustration
causing a supersonic speed to shut down
the entire power grid in the
northwestern united states
the u.s authorities eventually send
scientist dr robotnik to investigate the
incident
sonic meets police officer tom bukovsky
during his escape who fearfully sedates
him
this causes the ellen hatchet to trip
which is why his portal rings end up on
the west coast in san francisco to be
exact
tom eventually helps sonic escape and
travels with him to california so he can
get his important rings back
after the two slowly become friends
sonic is again
knocked unconscious by one of robotnik's
attacks tom brings his new pal to his
wife matty vykovsky who ends up joining
the two in search of the rings
at the transamerica pyramid in san
francisco the three faced the mad
robotnik and with the help of one of his
rings
sonic saves both tom and maddie in the
final battle
tom and sonic managed to use a portal
ring to send dr robotnik to a mushroom
planet following the clear victory sonic
decides to stay with his new family in
green hills though of course his
robotnik survived the whole procedure
and now vows revenge
in a mid-credits scene at the end you
get to see the two-tailed fox tales
finding his way to earth
a sequel was a foregone conclusion after
the movie crossed an impressive 310
million us dollars despite the
outbreak of the pandemic for a long
period of time there was no information
about the sequel's plot based on the
mid-credits scene it was merely assumed
that sonic's longtime friend tales would
make an appearance
for a few days now however the mystery
about the plot is not quite as
mysterious anymore
as the complete synopsis of the sequel
was accidentally published on the
website
of the us copyright office according to
the synopsis tom and maddie go on
vacation and leave sonic at home in
green hills as
you can imagine this is not a good idea
at all since dr robotnik has found his
way back to earth
so far not too surprising however
the mad scientist is not alone as has
been speculated in the past
knuckles is at robotnik side this time
the scientist's attention is not only on
sonic but mainly on a mysterious emerald
that has the power not only to destroy
entire civilizations
but also to create them of course if
this weapon were to be in robotnik's
hands this would be disastrous which is
why tails and sonic set out on a mission
to prevent robotnik and knuckles from
achieving their goal
although the official synopsis answered
a lot of questions there are still some
aspects that haven't been clarified yet
first is the question of sonic's home
planet where he's been chased by a group
of enemies
this group is neither mentioned by name
nor do we see a representative in the
movie who could solve the mystery
it is possible that it is the knuckles
clan known mostly from the video games
this clan spent most of its time on rage
trying to take over the powerful chaos
emeralds ultimately
they failed under the ruthless leader
which meant the downfall of the clan
possibly in the sonic cinematic universe
the clan has regained its own strength
and wants to capture the blue hatchet to
learn more about its superpower and who
could be better qualified for the job
than knuckles himself
the red echidna has been known since the
video game sonic the hedgehog 3 in which
he's manipulated by robotnik into
thinking that sonic wants to steal the
emeralds
later on knuckles realizes robotnik's
foul play and befriend sonic it seems
like the storyline of the video game
could easily be picked up in the sequel
but who knows maybe there will be
another mind-bending plot twist awaiting
us
now we want to go into more detail on
the new additions to sonic 2.
especially for fans of the movie who are
not so well-versed in the video games we
have prepared some
interesting information our first
character is the already mentioned
knuckles the red echidna is one of the
most popular characters in the sonic
universe even though as we said before
he cooperates with robotnik at first his
superpowers include close combat with
his spiky gloves and climbing walls
quickly
he is the last surviving member of the
knuckles clan and rather serious and
determinant character in spite of often
being a bit too gullible as well
one vulnerability is certainly his quick
temper which occasionally causes
knuckles to lose his composure even when
dealing with friends
although he's not as fast as sonic he's
clearly stronger and more battle-tasted
which makes him not only one of the
strongest characters in the franchise
but also one of the most popular
the other character already touched upon
in the mid-credits scene
is miles per hour alias tales his name
miles prower
is a reference to the english speed
measurement miles per hour
he's a welcome guest in numerous sonic
games and not just due to the yellow fox
likeable demeanor his character
contrasts with that of knuckles those
tails is rather modest and nice
in addition he is incredibly smart and
very well versed in the field of
technology
his most famous superpower consists of
being able to fly with his two rotating
tails
tails doesn't need to hide from sonic's
supersonic speed since dance is one of
the few characters capable of keeping up
with sonic he reaches his speed by
curling up into a ball
a couple of weeks ago filming on sonic 2
was completed
appropriately director jafala posted a
picture of himself sitting in a field of
mushrooms
small reference to the planet to which
robotnik was teleported
the hard work really begins in
post-production though after all the
video game characters have to be
animated and added to the footage first
in addition to the large production team
around toby asher tim miller and others
the voice actors and the actress who
will be appearing
are of particular interest unfortunately
not much is known so far except that jim
carrey is back in the role of dr
ivo robotnik and that james marston and
tikka sumter will again play the
waykovsky couple
sonic voice actor ben schwartz will also
be back though it is still
completely unclear who will be dubbing
tales and knuckles
a couple of months ago we did report
about rumors surrounding the sink of
newcomer knuckles
aquaman star jason mamoa and dwayne the
rock johnson were both mentioned as
potential voice actors in the reports it
remains to be seen whether one of them
will
indeed lend his voice to the fan
favorite character
until the release of sonic the hedgehog
2 on april 8 2022 we will no doubt
find out even more exciting information
which we will of course publish in our
weekly news
if you're looking forward to the first
trailer you should definitely subscribe
to our channel in order to not miss it
as we expect it to be online at the
latest by late october or
early november that's it for our latest
video
what are your hopes for the upcoming
sequel and what are your speculations
regarding the plot
let's discuss in the comments if you
liked the video feel free to leave a
like
see you next time
[Music]
recently some said photos of the
shooting of sonic the hedgehog 2
did the rounds on it you can see sonic's
companion knuckles
this confirms the appearance of the
popular character as there were already
some rumors about the echidna last year
one picture even shows sonic tails
and knuckles at the same time similar to
the shooting of the first sonic
but his statures besides that a photo
proves that actors james marston
and tikka sumter are coming back
allegedly there are plans for aquaman
star jason momoa to take over the
dubbing of knuckles
but this has not yet been officially
confirmed paramount sonic the hedgehog 2
is set to be released on april 8 2022
bye